ça fait pas peur c'est juste trop bien
des dromadaires en pleine ville le temps
d'une journée la Mauritanie et ses
emblèmes à quatre pattes se sont invités
au Mureaux ici c'est pas ça il a une
dizaine d'années il est né à Maubeuge
donc il est chez nous dans notre ferme
et c'est un mal castré et aujourd'hui
c'est lui le chef puisque en fait les
chameaux sont attachés en caravane pour
promener les gens et Pacha c'est le
premier pour cet événement la ville
s'est associée à l'Office national de
tourisme de Mauritanie parmi les
participants une délégation
mauritanienne a fait le déplacement
spécialement pour l'événement le but de
la journée faire découvrir les richesses
du pays tout en montrant la force de la
diversité des Mureaux pour nous c'est
très vraiment un événement important
c'est la première fois qu'on organise ce
genre de choses aux Mureaux et en fait
on voulait mettre à l'honneur une des
nombreuses communautés présentes sur la
ville des Mureaux au programme de cette
journée une présentation de la
Mauritanie au travers d'un maquillage
sensoriel avec des dégustations des
champs une initiation à l'artisanat
local et aux traditions comme la
découverte de la tente mort la
Mauritanie je sais que c'est un des plus
un des plus beaux endroits au monde donc
c'était l'occasion de voir un peu enfin
qu'elle puisse découvrir les odeurs les
couleurs les enfin la musique
oui c'est ça aussi la nourriture tout
plein de choses comme ça face au succès
de l'événement d'autres journées de
découverte culturelles pourront bientôt
être mises en place de quoi enchanter à
nouveau les rues des Mureaux
[Musique]